*melancholy piano music intro*
Well, helloooo. Oh, how's it goin'?
*mark reading*: Find a way out of the house, take away the valuables
So Imma BURGLAR!
In this game, where it says "Don't Play With the Dolls" ...Imma buuurglar
*intrigued ohh?*
OKAY, well, what kind of things am I gonna "burgle" (???)
Oh, I'm real slow
Alright, well, I'll--I'll play with dolls if I FEEL like it
And how will I know when there's things of value??
Nice--woAH
Do I have b00bs?
Heeell YEAH *chuckles* Oh, HELL YEAH!
I've got b00bs!
Heeeell yeah, owoh, look at meee!
Heeey, how's it goin' there? ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Either that, or I've got incredible pectoral muscles
But I think I got b00bs...heeey, how's it goin' there?( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Anyway, get ready to watch a lets-play that's gonna be entirely shot from a downward angle
*Auh du dodododo do-do-doo do la do dodododo*
OH
Press "E" to open?
Oh *opens*
*Realization gasp* I snuck in through the attic! That makes seeense! Okay, alright
*whimpy in-game "ow"*
Owww *laughs* what the hell?
Uh oh
O-kayyy
HmMMMmM
Well, why did I go in this place...
...in the first place?
WHY'D I do this?
I'm just gonna be honest, this seems like a bad idea ALL across the board
Is there gonna be some jumpscares in here?
This seems like the type of game that would have a lot of jumpscares...
And I'm just gonna go out on a limb here and say that there's gonna be...TONS of jumpscares...
I don't even see anything of VALUE
I'm not able to GRAB anything...
It's not like there's any MONEY here...
Am I here looking for something specific?
Okaaay...
Who's--who's *sudden crash*
*le gasp*
Who's playin' the windchimes over there?? Alright...
I dun like this
OH
Looks like there might be some DOLLS in here!
Okaaay...
Cigar box...
It's a blue triangle
Needed that in the other game I was playin'
Red circle there! All the things that I needed in the other game
Anything in here? No, there's nothing! Like, what am I even doing??
There's NOTHING that I can interact with!
If I'm supposed to take--OH
You know what I just realized?
This looks like that house from the game--uh--where you're tryna steal valuables from the house!
Like--like, uhh, THIEF-something. Sneaky thief, somethin' like that
I can't remember what it was called, but you guys remember that one, right??
I'm not crazy...
Okay, it seems ODDLY cheerful. I think it's trying to lull me into a false sense of security here and I don't like that
Okaay...
I still have no idea what I'm doin...
THE VERY ORGANIZED THIEF!
That was it--THAT was it! What I said was NOT it
Can I hide in here?
Okay, so I CAN, but what would be the point of that? I don't know why I need to hide...
That's the first thing that I've been able to interact with this ENTIRE time...
*le gasp*
I dun like this room
This feels like a BAD room
Ohhh...
OHHHH...
Ooookaaaay...
Moooon
SOMEthin'...
SOMEthin'?
*whispers* what the hell's goin' on?
I don't...get...what I'm...DOIN
Also, this seems VERY, like, DIFFERENT than everything ELSE that I was seeing in this place, so--
OHHH
HOW LOVELY, what was the point of that? Bu--but what would be--
*Mark reads:* When the moon shines in the sky, the traveler will be protected"
There's moon ones...
Is THAT what I'm supposed to do??
Noo? What am I doing?! Why am I here?!
Why am I doing ANY of this??
What does it all MEAN?!
I think this is gonna tak--yeah, this is back to the kitchen
What the hell does this all MEAN???
Can't go in there...THAT'S all locked up
Okay, there's one more place that I haven't seen
And that's THIS weird--oh, this isn't even a door, that's just off it's hinges
WHAT am I doing?!?
I was told there was gonna be dolls--I don't see any dolls!
I got a wierd mannequin here with a bunch of MOONS
I dunno WHAT the fuck's goin' on...
I'm LOST in a BUILDING
and NO ONE'S given me ANY directions. I thought that was something on the WALL over there
Turns out it was NOT
GOT SOME--maaatches (?)
DA'RIGHT
Oh
OH
So there ARE parts...
There ARE things to take...
Well, I wish I WOULD'VE KNOW THAT
I wish somebody would've told me THAT
WHAT THE HELL?! How did someone not tell me that?!
A'right, wutever
Okay, so I gotta find these blue pieces or somethin'? I-It's talkin' about the moon, right?
There's gotta be, like, a piece of the moon
Whatever it was talkin' about...so
If I can just find them, wherever THEY are...
This is gonna be a big hunt through the house
Wind chimes stopped...
As a matter of fact, everything...stopped-
Now I'm seeing...
-match lights up- ...thing...
...Am I seeing something or is that--
OKAY GOD I thought--oh my god
that scared the crap outta me, I thought
I thought that thing
was two arms of someone
dangling down. -sigh- Apparently
not though. Okay so--what do I need to do...
So there must have been something upstairs
that I overlooked because it seems like
this was in more of a...readily
available place, so I was
Oh! I don't think I went down this way
So I must have missed something...
Can I light this? -match lights the candle- Yeah... I can
Okay! There we go, wasted a match but that's okay
*gasp*
I found the doll
Well la-de-da
How are you doing?
C-can't open that...
Maybe I don't want to open that.
HEYYYYY
How you doin' (Haha Joey)
You good?
Oh you look good, okay, so you're not going to like...
Sneak up on me when I turn my back, are ya?
You're not just gonna like
Murder me... as soon as I drop my guard are ya?
Oh here we go
Clock pocket... Okay then
*creepy music picks up*
That was a bit more... dramatic then it needed to be
Kaaayyyyyy
*Mark messes around with buttons*
What does this do... Nothing?
Oh- KAY I don't trust that it's just NOTHING
*scary sound= creeped out Markimoo face*
The fuck was that?
okay...
*rip headphone users* WHAT THE FU- WOAH WOAH WAY WOAH WHAT THE FUCKING....
*sad music= bewildered Markimoo face*
EXCUuuuseee YOu
UHHHHHhhhhmmmm-uh
AHhhhhhhh
okay... alright...
well... that's bullshit
That's bullshit and you know that's bullshit so don't play that bullshit with me when you know that's bullshit
Find the way out of the house, take away the valuables
Ohhh kay
Alright, fine then
We're going to do this again, and you're not going to be bullshit to me
*Mark mimics character grunt*
I wasn't even looking at my boobs for good luck
alright
I'm looking for valuables, now I know what to look for
It's the small objects on top of tables and the such as
Let's just go immediately to the doll room
And see if we can do something about this
Hello, again
How you doing, is it going to be the same thing up here?
Yeah, it's going to be the same thing, okay grab this
grab that...
*more spoopy music* SO that must be what starts the whole experience here and I don't know why
OH
There he is
Okay so, he's over there- OH he's a comin
Okay so, if I go in here and I HIDE
Then I should be just fine, RIGHT?
Should be totally fi- OHhh
HEY BUDDY
Mark: Oh buddy- *while freaky clown says "Where are you?"*
*Mark mimics clown* Where are you?
HOHO ho ho (Mark that's not Santa)
um
Creepy Clown in distance: Wannnaaa playyyyyyy
Okay... I guess I win then
*opens closet door prematurely*
*Startled Markimoo sounds*
*sad you ded music, while Mark looks skeptical*
*Skeptical look intensifies*
Alright
I had a lot of hopes for this game, it did set quite a mood in the beginning of it
*Radioactive breath*
NOW not as much
Now not as much
Now not as much, I'm going to give it ONE more go
Just one more go
And then we're going to have a great time
I-eh-uh- It's so fascinating because at first I was literally like
*mimicking 9 minute ago Mark* this seems really good, I'm gettin spoo-
OH, I'm gettin' chills down my spine here
Gettin' all the tingley wiggleys about it
And then a  whole lot of nothing
Oh it's in the same place, GOOD, that's awfully conveninent
Oh I've got the hiccups *hic* OH somebody help me *hic*
Somebody help me ohMYGOD
Okay so... I don't think that there was anything else down here
I looked at pretty much everything and it didn't seem like there would be
So if I bolt in there, I grab the thing and then I bolt out I should be fine right?
*Mark scatting*
And turn this on for whatever that does
Okay and then I'm out
I'm outtie
AND I'm down the stairs, he'll never get me
So what does that do, I don't even know what that does
*radio making noises*
*Mark is very confused*
okay
alright
I'm giving you a shot here game
Impress me!
So I've got this piece of like half-moon something
This has got to go somewhere, right?
Or maybe it's just a valuable
OH
Maybe this is...
shook Mark*
*confused Mark*
Thought I heard something...
Okay, maybe not...
OH
WHY-WHY COME ON MAN NOOOO COME ON YOU CLOWN BASTARD
GET- no- GO. GOD- Oh god. okay.
fine
you clown bastard
so... OH COME ON NOW
You SASSY HAND-WAVING PIECE OF SHIT (very articulate Mark)
*Mark mocking clown again* WHere are you I've lost ye
*Normal voice* Why are you a pirate?
Can I get out of here please?
Can I leave?
Can I hide?
Is hiding even going to be worth- Okay- well- nope- oh
*Mark dies again*
*dead music plays again, but Mark is done*
*considers restart button*
*wants to click Main menu button*
*Damn what a sexy main menu button*
*looks at viewers*
*Slow Radioactive breath*
I paid money for this
I think that's good enough
It's good enough for that
That's good enough right there, That's good enough RIGHT THERE
Let's just move on!
We played it
We gave it a chance
Maybe there's more to the game maybe there IS more to the game
I don't know if I could find it
I don't have the patience for that
BUT
ITS OKay
It did set up good atmosphere it's just like, once that clown showed up...
It became a LOT- lot less fun
So we're gonna re- we're gonna- we're just gonna leave it right there
*New game*
Okay this one's called "Need a Packet"
I don't remember downloading this, I don't remember buying it
Just showed up! (that's not good Mark)
*mouth farts*
*Really confused Mark has no clue what to do*
....why.....
*tongue noise* Why would you do that?
*Mark literally just can't with these games today*
No
E-En
Ru- Ohhhhhh
*still looks confused* the fuck...
OH
Restart day, new job-
*still confused*
This money...? What? What do I need money for?
Alright, let's just go
Easy...?
*Mark just can't*
TWO DIFFICULTIES! Easy and Insane!
Let's go insane (right cause you're not confused already, great choice Mark)
I don't know what I'm DOING (then why'd you pick insane)
What IS this?
Are you NAKED?!
I'm going to get BANNED
Hang on, wait...
*pretends to be naked person*
*makes fun of himself* I'M GONNA GET BANNED
I'M NAKED
THERE'S MY DICK
oR MAYBE THESE ARE MY BOOBS, I DON'T KNOW
I'M GONNA GET BANNED
FBI PLEASE NO
*fbi breaks down Mark's door*
*serious Mark* Alright, I can't be late for work... today's the first day
Do I...
OH, oh
OH- those there *flustered, giggling Mark*
Those WERE boobs!
Alright, don't know why you were just standing in the middle of your room completely buttass na-
what is that?
Oh! Drugs?
There's apparently drugs behind my head
wait, let me
Maybe I should be over here
hang on I'm um-
I'm movin' myself
No one panic
GOD
There we go, there I go, I'm going on an adventure
FLIP
Man, what is this?
I've got drugs up here
I dunno what those are for
I guess nothin'
Oh, I hate that
Ook, well I can't be over here now cause of fu- OKAY we're going back, here we gooooooo
*derp face and derp noise*
annnnddd flip!
What the fuck is this?
"No, I just want to air this. Yes... Why we're still taking money from them? No... What? We're on Ahem."
What the fuck
okay...
"Can heal, More furniture, One more defender..."
*surprised*  Defender? ... What the fuck?
"Make our city clea..."
Whaaat the fuckkk
"Hey! Welcome to the job. So it's actually easy."
"Today's a trial day. You ask if they need a package and if they do - you give it."
whattt?
"Hello everyone, it's Aldan, and today we are making cheese 'maaffins'".
"160g of corn flour, 120g of whole 'whaat' flower, 300mL of 'malllk', 150g of hard cheese...
"50g of butter, 1tsp of sugar (I have the coconut one), 1tsp of slacked soda or 1tsp of 'backing' powder...
...Sift both toops of floower and mix it togoother. Add all the other dro ingrodients. Moox it.
...Melt the butter on the stove. Add" *mark stutters* miwiwiwah...
Whaat the fuck
dude!
What the...
"Put dough into muffin forms. Preheat an oven to the 190 degrees Celsius and bake our muffins for 20-30 minutes"
"Enjoy!"
the fuck?
*nonsense*
"Goodmorning! Coming up..." what the fuckk
Theres an arrow behind my head
Start the day for gods sake
huh what
What is this... papers police?
"You shouldn't sell packages. This is bad for all of us"
"Need a packet?"
here you gooo
milk...
thank you...
yesss?
okay, you need a packet? Alright hang on...
hu... how do I...
five... thank you
*whispers* What the fuck is this?
Why is there just a pot here?
You do need a packet.
I don't understand anyyything thats... goddamn it, well there goes all...
... I know theres a ten... I put those in the... okay well it's unlimited.
there it is
and theres the five, and theres... no. Thats the ten
WHY? WHAT THE FUCKK?
the tea was five...
wha... I've got negative money now. I've got negative money!
What da fuck... WHAT IS THIS GAME?
alright fine i'll move... hang on I'm gonna move this to the... how do I move it?
ah I've got no saved space
There, I guess I'm here now
tea please. Ten... heres your change.
Theres your change, and theres... and the.. and theres. Heres your change.
there you gooo
there you are
ohhkayy..
... now I'm doing it right
End of the day
I'm naked again... Why am I naked?!!!
I have no... money... and I don't understand
what the fuck
so its a...
it's a simulator of being a cashier at a grocery store
I'm gonna keep going on it
"Hello everyone, its Aldin and today were gonna continue making rasgulla"
"our soft cheese we can either rub through a sleeve or use blendar"
alright I guess I can't be here now
I don't know
I don't know...
"After rubbing it we'll have that nice and soft mass...
use it to form balls each a..." what the fuu. Ahhkay
"bigger rasgulla grows over three times its size...
My three liters of milk make about 10-15 (he means 25-30) pieces"
why am I playing a... what the fuck
I've never seen a m-more bizarre game than this game right here
I've never. Okay but I'm gonna stop being flabbergasted by it
I'm gonna... through sheer force of will I'm gonna stop being flabbergasted by this
and Im gonna take this fucking seriously, and I expect all of you...
all of you to... what happened to the soup? why is it black?
I expect all of you to take it equally as seriously because if you do not take this seriously...
this will not go well
"One day little girl did not get pies.."
Great story!
thank you
"need packet?" noo
halva
this is not enough
you need more money
more mo-  there we go...
smart...
me have money now
think think think
okay now I've got it
need a packet? oh you need a packet wait
*boop*
and put it in oh- put it in
put. put it. put it in the packet
out the packet over... here have a packet
kay, you've got a packet
coffee... tea... soap
doo and doo...
and a packet!
*inhales*
god... okay I got it...
why do I only get one dollar for that?
thats hard... this is hard
this game...  *sighs*
I feel like I'm playing some horrible math blaster from a different dimension
im gonna stop being flabbergasted
im gonna stop...
being...
flabbergasted
Im going to stop... being...
flabbergasted.
what is the appeal of this game?
honestly... I don't know
I really don't know
I don't know what I am doing
I don't know why I am doing it
I don't know if theres some surreal other meaning to this game
I... I really honestly, truly don't understand
what is... like what is the purpose of this game?
obviously someone put a lot of work into this game...
this is like a health bar of some kind
theres a lot of...
whats with the barnacles?
but what is...
*whispers* what is the point?
theres something more here but I don't get it
theres got to be! like...
it wouldn't just BE this right?
I mean it's kind of... relaxing? I guess
at its best its relaxing?
I still have negative seven dollars, but I, like I guess its kind of interesting
I need five... oh.
alright...
im bailing
I'm... bail. Bail! Bail! Bail! Bail hard
Bailing hard on that one
just, I... can't
I can't... I can't think of nothing even to say. I can't think of anything to do
I have no idea what that is about. I have NO idea
I have no idea. BUT that was "Need a Packet"
The name of the game was "Need A Packet"
*mouth smack*
no idea...
*new game intro music*
okay looks familiar... NO I've played this one
haven't I?  No I
NO I pla...
*confused markimoo*
I kno... I played this one
*whispers* what?
This isn't ringing any bells, but its kind of oddly familiar
was there an update?
"How did this happen, this is not how it was meant to be. We were meant to get married... Ive played this one!
*glass shatters and mark poops his pants* fuck...
*door creaks*
the fuck
no I've played this
haven't I?
*door slams loudly*
shit
No I've... what the fuck
I've played this!
hang on... I've. what the fuck. Why was it in... I've played this!!
How about play it again
here we go... were just gonna play through it again
why not? have some fun! live a little! COME ONNNN
whats so baaadd about it!?
AHH a plain old classic everybody plays games that they love over and over again right?
wh... what do I do?
I don't even know what I do. What do I do? Go on and take a sleep? Go nap?
okay... were gonna
were gonna go ta... okay I got nothing
Well, I've uh...OH?
THAT'S NEW!
Did that happen before?! Noo! Wai--noooo! That's new! Waiiit what da fuck
*lights shatter*
*Mark waves* Hi
*Mark is seriously cunfuzzled*
*le gasp
*whispers* the baaaby...
*whispers* I remember the baby...
*Mark reads the note*
*sudden crash* woAH--
I do--I did play this before
I don't KNOW if it's been updated at all, but...hm
I'm not 100% sure about that..
*sudden dramatic boom*
*sudden dramatic boom* *again*
Ahh, that's--that's an issue
That's uhh--that's a no good--oHh, I probably need this
Excuse me, I'll take this
*sudden dramatic boom*
Ah- I don't remember that!
*sudden dramatic boom* *again*
Am I gonna get squooshed?
Oh shit--I am
Uh--Ho--Uhoh
*sudden dramatic boom*
Aaah
*different dramatic boom*
Bwahh
I don't remember that
I don't remember that!
Wait, is it new?
*Mark reads the note*
Helen is pregnant, we did not plan this
*Mark stops reading*
Why didn't I use a goddamn condom? I'm just such an idiot
Goddamn it!
Arrrgg!
rawrr-oH
What, am I just dead and it's just starting over--or is that supposed to happen?
I didn't see an escape--Well there was a key
OH WAIT
WAIT, is that the same way I died beforeee?!
Okay- after this we're gonna go back and we're gonna watch that video together
*mouth smack*
Cause I don't remember fucking ANY of this
I don't remember a goddamn thing here
The fuck--I don't remember this
Like I remember contextually like kind of this
But it just blurs together with everything else
*Mark reads note*
How'd this happen *stops reading note*
OH-How did it happen?!
I put my penis in
I took my penis out
I put my penis in again
And then I shook it all about
And suddenly she's pregnant!
I don't get it!
How did this happen?!
*lightbulb shatters*
Ah-Shit
So they've got- there was something else that you gotta do
We're gonna- we're gonna play through this
we're gonna play through this
we're gonna play- *gets interrupted by loud noise*
*pretends to be scared*
*is done with everything again*
So what door am I supposed to unlock with the key again? I don't even know
*game makes loud noise* Okay I- got this
*more loud game noises*
Oh, there we go- easy peasy I guess
*creepy lullaby music* Nah... It's the same, I remember it now
Oh! I Rem- OHHHHH NOW I REMEMBER IT
*Mark reading* "Finally... It is silent. I thought doing this would help me but I still cannot sleep"
*Still reading* "What have I done. My mind is lost without her... I need you Helen"
Well maybe you shouldn'ta killed that baby
Anyways, see ya
"I'm coming for ya"
*game making scary noise*
Who? Who?
*scariness intensifies*
Why! Is that a baby?
*Mark doesn't know what he is doing despite having played this before*
Oh!
*Mark pretending to be scared*
*silence*
*gunshot* Wha- OH FUCK OFF
Oh I didn't make it- Ah fuck off and fuck you!
Oh fuck- fuck youuuuuu
Fuck- yeah, yeah I'm out- I'm out- I'm out
We're not watching that, we're going to watch some wholesome Markiplier content
We're going to watch something really high quality- a Markiplier video
Here we go!
*starts laughing at old video thumbnail*
Oh yeah! Wait! I remember... wait! Okay...
Ah, this one? Yeah, there we go, okay
What the fuck?
I remember that!
Why did I do that? And then- *old Mark interrupts* "Hi everybody my name is MARKiplier"
"And welcome to hotel remorse" *jumpscare sound, makes Mark pause video* What the fuck?
"This is the CREEPIST shit I've ever seen in my entire life"
"Holy hell"
"Who made this mask
"ew"
"Just, uh- just having it look at me is just awful"
"Anyway. HORROR GAME, nothing I need to explain anymore"
"LET'S PLAY!"
Hang on, I gotta move this, gotta do like, a side-by-side comparison of this
*Mark looks at himself* Alright me, here we go me! Alright, you got this me! Alright let's do this!
"Alright, *old Mark reading* Saturday October 2nd, between the times of 2 and-"
*Mark interrupts* You know what's weird? I look a lot more like my brother
Right here
In this- in this moment
Like I look a lot like my brother
And I don't know why
Like me and my brother we kinda look similar
But I have like my dad's face and my brother has my mom's face
Like mine's longer face and he has like a more rounded face
but right here I look a LOT like my brother
*restarts video* "two and three am there were several reports made-"
*Mark pause video and mocks self* Between 2 and 3 am there were several reports being made-
What kind of voice is that you fucking prick
*restarts video* "of a single gunshot heard from a hotel. The occupants of the hotel quickly vacated the building in-"
*Mark interrupts again* The occupants of the hotel quickly- What the fuck are you doing?
Stop being such a try hard you piece of shit!
*restarts video* "in search of safety' Except for ME!"
*Mark pauses again to mock* Except for me- what are you doing- man
*gunshot makes old Markiplier have a seizure*
"FUCK- oh that was that gunshot you were talking about"
"Holy crap! Let me turn down my volume a little bit"
*now Mark nods his approval* Yeah it was loud as balls- that is true
*Old Mark reading* "We will get through this and soon be married having the rest of our lives to be with one another"
"And this baby" *Mark is disgusted with himself*
*Mark mocking himself again* And this baby- And this baby
"This is a weird hotel, I'm turning my volume back up! Just because! You never-"
*Mocking himself again* Just because! Honestly...
My voice did change a lot over the years
And it's-it's really weird to like actually listen in on an old video of mine
Because, it comes down to where for a while there, it wasn't natural
Like, cause I was trying to do the thing where I was projecting
Projecting was like- it was- it was just weird feedback
*get's distracted* Look, I have the exact same headphones though- I've been keeping these headphones for forever
Uhm, but, it was this weird moment where I would like project
And it would just like encapsulate this bizarre, like, announcer-y voice
It's not like my voice didn't have qualities that I wanted out of it
It was just like- I was just trying VERY hard to concisely do this cause
You've got to admit, this is only like... what? three years after I started?
And it was just like, after the- the incident of the Octodad..
After my voice like, intentionally changed
And it took a long time to fight out of that habit
Like that was- these are BAD habits as far as vocal, uh, training goes
So- it- like I learned a lot from this moment
Anyway, here we go *restarts video* "Never know what could happen"
*Mark mocks himself again* Never knowww what could happen
Also my mic now is a lot better then my mic back then *stutters a little*
And my audio processing is much better then it was back then too, so
*proud of himself* I learned
"I mean obviously I'm supposed to vacate but there's someone who has got a GUN around here"
*mocks* Got a GUN around here
That is just a bizarre thing...
Cause when I was recording these, like, I knew that there was a distinct difference from when I was like, recording, recording and like, when I was talking
And now it's like, like I'm just talking like as I would normally talk
But, it's just super weird to go back and listen to this
*old Mark reading* "She was the important one*
*glasses breaking sound makes old Mark lose his shit* "AH FUCK"
I remember that sound effect, that's actually- that's a sound bite that a lot of people have used, maybe I've used that in a compilation or something
*Ambiance scares old Mark* "AH FUCK AH"
"OHHHHHHH GAWD NEVERMINDDDDDDD"
"OHHHHHH GAWDDDDD-"
*scared old Mark, unimpressed now Mark*
What a bitch baby
What a pathetic little bitch (over) "Alrighty then that's one helluva warm up for my voice"
*Old Mark chuckles nervously*
Yeah, and that's the other thing like- I would lose my voice all the time, because
I was- I was speaking unhealthily when I was making let's plays
Like I was speaking with way too much pushing
It was also a factor of like- I couldn't exactly hear myself
No I've got better monitoring software-
I've got an audio interface that allows me to hear myself at whatever volume I want
I can mix, on-demand, the volume of the game vs the volume of my voice
So I can always hear myself, like I'm turning my own volume up in my headphones so I can hear myself very clearly
And when you get in a feedback loop, or when you can't hear yourself you end up like screaming cause you like- you naturally wanna hear yourself, so it's just weird
*baby crying noises* Oh I'm scared Scary baby...  *old Mark* "You're not the important one!"
"I'm a meannnn man"
*Mark whispering obscenities towards his past behavior*
*Past Mark reading* "I have no one. I'm left here alone in this darkness."
Actually I can't really criticize that cause I do that all the time now anyways, just like
Imma MEan MaN
Just my voices are slightly beTTER THAN YOURS FUCKO
You fucking inattentive asshole....
*innocent past Mark* "How do I get to customer service? They better do something about this!"
"Seems to be leaking nightmares from"
*Old Mark says Hell like a weirdo*
The fuck was that?
*Mark replays it*
What the fuck did I- What was that?!
Oh here, I bet I die here, see I think...
*old Mark gets jump scared*
"Ohhhhh okay its coming towards me, okay I'm going to get this thing"
"Whatever it is, I want it!"
"I want it- okay I got it! Whatever it was"
"Ohhhh, its closing in on me"
Unlock noOOOOOO
NOoooo?
*confident Mark thinks old him messed up too* See yeah it was tricky!
"Crap I'm dead" *old Mark survives*
Oh *old Mark cackles in background at current Mark's failure*
"No, no, no, oh no none of that, oooHHHHH HI HOW'S IT GOING?"
"OHHH OKAYY"
"AH God! OH no, no-"
What is he worried about? He only shot a baby
Maybe you should stop beING SUCH A BITCH ABOUT IT
HUH?!?!
hUUUUUHHHHHH?!
HUUUHHHHH
*Mark repeating what the voices in his head said* You're so- you're so harsh over your past"
Yeah exactly- yeah, see? It's all good
It's all- You can be harsh about your past
I don't got any regrets about anything that I've done but its just funny to watch
Like I- I watch a lot of like my own videos just to like, self-evaluate
Like kinda like get an idea of where I am and where I- where I've been
I mean this is only- again this is only, what? Three years ago, so it's not that long ago
But it's like, yeah, it's super weird
*old Mark is still terrified by the game*
"AHHHHH NO KIDDING"
I had slightly better reaction times in this one then I did the other one but, there you go
"Charlie Behan, that was really good!"
*Mark interrupting old Mark* OH yeah wait, wait there is a cheap jump scare coming up
*skips to old Mark mourning the loss of T-Bag* "Ohhhh how could it happen? That was really good though!"
"I enjoyed that thoroughly! That-" *scared by jump scare* "FUCK YOU"
Enough of that! Back to business guys, Back to business. Enough having fun
That's not what this is about
Alright, you guys just wasted your opportunity because now it is time for another break
Ha got 'em! *Mark does a depressed dab*
Ah, fuck me I hate myself (same buddy)
*ominous intro music for next game*
"Dementia - Mom Is Home"
Welcome to this one
Apparently this is a playstation 4 - like game
Meant for that
But I don't have a playstation controller-I just got this Xbox controller
So we're gonna go with that
I think actually I do have a playstation controller over there
But I'm gonna see if it works with the Xbox first
*sigh*
Actually maybe I should just do it with -
*reaches for controller* *grunts*
Hang on let me see if-
Let me see if-
AH!
AHHH!
I dropped something...
Okay, I think if I just plug- oH
You think this is sacrilege?
I've got an Xbox USB adapter, and Im plugging it into a PlayStation
You think this is gonna be utter sacrilege? (yes, yes I do)
Probably...
You think- does this even work?
I don't know if this is gonna work
*USB plug-in noise*
Boop bo di doop!
Heard that!
Now I don't hear anything...
What happened?
Do- Okay well it worked! - No
Got to restart the game
Goddamn this shit
The shit I go through to try to give you guys a good experience! (tnx Mark)
When it comes down to games!
I should have just gone with the- WHATEVER
Here we go...
Alright- were going in again
No complaints-It's all good
Its all good
Its not working
It's not working...
Wasn't even worth doing!
Okay that didn't work
We'll put that away, and we'll just bust out-
Why did I even try?!
Why did I bother to try?!
Why did I try?!
What was even the point of trying?!
I was fine- everything was fine
Why did I try? I just needed to-
This is fine
I bet! I bet this is going to be fine
Here we are
Spooky!
Boop! There we go- Okay
It does work-Apparently
Alright- Here we go!
oh- oOO
It looks good
Veery nicee
I'm not sure why they out this out on PC if it was supposed to be a playstation demo
Maybe they just needed accessibility for it- For people to see it
Allrightt...
ooo
Okay- Oof
Why is everything so blurry? Oh my God that hurts my eyes
Im suuuper drunk I believe
Im just gonna try to very gently- non vomishly-
Navigate through this place
Okay, do I need water or should I turn this off?
"X"
Here we go
Sploosh- Ah!
Cleared all the dust out of my eyeballs- Now I can see good!
*noise comes from door*
Hello...
*noise again*
*noise*
kayy?
Find the keyyy??
To my own front dooorr?!
Why would I need that?
Why would that be a thing?- What is this?
Oh welp- Found the key to my own front door
I guess?
*doorknop is turned*
Hello?
Peek a boo
*lights flicker* *thunder*
What was...
Uhhh
Find and pick up the flashlight?
What was that?!
Grandma?!
Grandmaaa
Oh wait...
Uh Oh
*exhales*
There we go- Okay there we go
Good God- Okay now I can move
What what happened? I'm now crouched
Why am I-
There we go- Okay
I thought I was done because I was pressing buttons on the controller and it wasn't working-
But I think we're okay
Alright
Grab this- I've got this
Push- Pull...
*whispers* what the fuck?
*whispers* what?
What?
What the?
Wut?
*mark vigorously presses controller buttons*
Wha?
I ca-
I can't mo-
I can't move!
I ca-
*vigorously presses controller buttons*
*exhales*
*depressed exhale*
I just want to play the game...
Okay...
I want to turn OFF this contro-
I'm gonna-
Im gonna turn of this controller
Getting steamy up in here (hell yeah it is)
Its like you get one good game experience out of like six bad ones
And it's just like mann if like-
It's almost as if there should be some way to teach people like HOW TO MAKE GAMES PROPERLY!
Now I'm being shitty about it- Now I'm being shitty
And now I'm being shitty!
And you know what? I don't give a fuck if I'm being shitty about it!
Because like it should be simple- It should be simple!
Playing games should be just easy and simple, and FUN!
FUN!
FUN GAMES!
FUCK OFF!
Fun- I can't move
But I can press the menu button
This button brings up the menu
*vigorously presses menu button over and over*
*look of frustration*
okayy
I don't know why suddenly the Xbox controller broke
But we're gonna try this again
*mouth smack*
We're gonna try this again
I'm gonna plug the controller in directly
And that's going to fix all my problems (I wish life worked like that)
I guarantee- All of my problems are about to be solved
Nevermind
They are not
kay... I can't more with mouse and keyboard
I can only do this...
This is working- Okay that works
This no longer works...
Try restarting
And I'm not gonna be angry about it
It's a NEW opportunity
A new opportunity to- What the fuck
Suddenly...
I have motion controls enabled
Pretty good game huh?
A pretty good game!
Oh Imma go get him!
Here we goo!
I'm gonna get him!
YEAHHHH WE WON!
YEAH WE WON! Hell yeah guys!!
I'm going to throw up
I don't know what the fuck is happening here
I don't know why the fuck its happening but I can't play that game
SOO
YAAAAHOOOOEEEYYY!
YeeHaw baby
Man- And I wanted to play that game it looked great@
That game looked great!
But then it wasn't
let's do something else
Let's try this one...
It's called "Miss Eyesore"
*melancholy new game intro song*
So this is "Miss Eyesore"
oooOOoo
oh that looks spooky!!
*reads screen*
"This game contains flashing images, loud sounds and jumpsares"
I like the sound of that!- How to play
I don't like this
*reads game details*
*inhales*
Oh my God
*continues reading game details*
*sighs* My God
*continues reading*
*Mark struggles to live*
An essay is NOT good game design!
Alright lets do this- Got to get the generators 1-9
Got to make sure they don't break
But if they are breaking, then they got to break
Hello! Hello Hello!
*Mark reads screen*
Alright
"Read the transcript" I don't need to
SO
What was that about lights?
Shinin'
Flashin'
Dat seems bad
so...
The doors locked- It leads out but it is locked
uh oh
Six don't look so good!
Wait, where am I?
I'm here
Uh
Kay thats to the right
Okayy
Is this a generator?
ba da bing ba da boom baby!
Did that
Okay so I did that and then-
Okay
One, two and three are going out
*whispers* I don't know man
Generator is fine for now
Here we go...
Perfect!
Okay, so how do I know if Miss Eyesore is coming after me?
like- Will I have a clue or is she gonna pop out of nowhere?
Okay- Eight and seven
No- Oh wait no- Wait
Which way was eight?
Oh noI went the wrong way
It's all down this way
Okay oops
Well fuck me then
This ones fine down here
Man why do they need nine generators for this?
I mean if they're all breaking down all the time whats even the point of having them?
Alright
wu- wo wa
OH FUCK ME!
"You didn't close the door to generator 8 in time"
Ohkayy
Okay this- this- this
Okay whatever- Alright
Okay
Alright here we go!
Okay so I know this game
I only gotta survive five minutes
Theres a countdown on the top left
Okay number five- Easy peasy
Easy Peasy
Easyy peasyy
Easee my pazzizy
I've got a lot of pazzizle
My pazzizles are good
I've been known to have quality pazizzles
And nobody can argue that
Alright?- Okay we're good
Okay this one
Eazgy-Pazoozgy
Humzky pazumski
And amzgy pazozgi (these captions are a disaster)
What in the- What kind of
What kind of lame excuse is it that like these-
Like I'm trapped in here with all the generators
What are these powering besides just the lights?
Like this many generators
Like it would have to be something dramatic
Oh that might be going out soon
What the- Okay
Oh shi- OH SHIT
OH SHIT I'm closing that down
I closed off that other way but I don't know if that was a good idea
Because I may have lost those generators
But I think its better just to play it safe for this round
Not that one
Got it- Okay
Easy pazoozle (not again)
Can I just close this one too? Just because
Got it!
ooh! Now we get seven
Seven, Im on it!
I'm on it babe!
I'm on it!
I'm in it- I'm in it to win it
No Miss Eyesore for me
okay
Alright I ca- can deal with this like gameplay
This gameplay's nice- But just the instructions for it weren't too good-
Like you could do an escalating thing
For it if you wanted to
Nothing over here
ooo number five again
OOO don't break, don't break rrrgh
Haboo
Okay- goodx8
And is this one breaking?
Seems like it might be breaking
Yeahhhh okay alright mmm I'm goood
I'm good baby- Im good at this game!
uh why are you breaking again you son of a shit?!
You think you can jus- I turn my back and you just break?!
You stupid piece of crap!
Oh man I'm gonna run out of power
So all of those are broken now
Were looking at number eight- Okay
Eight, I'm coming to you baby!
Eight you think I would leave you behind?
The answer is no
Shit
There we go
Alright I'm just gonna peak over here to make sure that this one isn't breaking
Kay, seems fine
Okay- I got this!
I understand this!
I can see how this is going
Oh shit!
Noo this isn't going to be good
Ohh shit
Oh- OHHH NO WAY
NOPE!
NO WAY
Not going down there!
Okay that's bad
Oh that's bad!
How in the fuck?!
Do-
Oh Go- OH GOD
OH GOD
OH- Oh God!
Oh I- uh- FUCK
Uhh- Fuck
Um fuck
Okay well I'm fucked
Uhhhh
Ummm
Uhh
I have this- Wait
I forgot to-
Oh fuck off
Come on just let me- I have
OH FUCK OFF!
NO FUCK IM TRYING TO SHOW PEOPLE SOMETHING
STOPPP! DONT KILL ME!
Right there
Uh Oh
WOAH!
Woahhh
Okayy
And there we have it- I'm dead
*whispers*  How in the fuck
*whispers* How would you do that?
How would you do that?
How would you do this?
Like it's- That would be almost impossible
Alright I'm gonna give it one more try
I'm gonna give it one more try and it's gonna be good
I'm gonna- I'm gonna do it more by like when I'm in an area I'm gonna listen
Cause this feels like it would just be almost impossible
Alright- I'm going
Okay that seems fine
I guess I can look for like flashing lights
Cause if anythings flashing then I would be guessing that-
Oh I can shift to run
I wasn't sprinting
Oh well it was broken
Okay so I wasn't sprinting
Why would they have two modes?
Why wouldn't you always be going as fast as you could go?
That just seems silly
Okay
You should ALWAYS be going as fast as you sho..could go
OH MY GOD- OH MY GOD
Okay great
Oh fuck me then!
Is this one okay?
This ones okay?
Alright you're fine
Why did I even bother looking?!
Who else? Who else? Who else?
Ahh fuck!
Well thats not good
Okay pleasee
Okay uhhhhh- Ughhh
Ughhh!
Uh oh
Okay not that one!
Thats okay!
Okay thats bad
This ones going down
It's okay though
Ughhhh
Okay this is stressful!
I will admit this game is very stressful
Like very stressful
Okay I closed that one down- We're okay for now
Ohh I'm off
I'm off
It's better to lose just one than an entire wing of 'em
Thats for sure
Which is what I panic-did the last time
Okay
Okay- One generator is now down again but which one is it?
Oh of course it was- The one farthest away from where I was
Of course it was gonna be that one
Why would it be anything else?
Thats fine for now, sure it is
Okay whatever you say...
"eeeebooski"
Okay, I'm probably super behind
On everything
"Ahhhhhbooski"
Okay what else we got?
What am I missing?
How am I failing?
I'm failing like that? You got it buddy
Im failing (me too)
I love it- I love failing (I don't)
Okay, here we go
Ooh SHITT!
DWAHHH
DAAAAHHH
Okay was that one fine?
Was that one broken?
Okay it was not broken- But NOW it is
Okay now it's broken
I think I'm gonna- I might make it this time
I may make it- Ooh NO I might not
No I might not
NOO don't break! don't break! don't break!
Okay we're good
Okay got that one
How are you doing? You good?
Okay, you good
Okay what do we got?
UGHH Eight- Eight and seven
Okay got it
"Uhhhhhh booski!"
And what have we got- Oh
You just did that! When did you do that?
Okay you're good- I've only got a minute forty-five left
Do I have enough time to go down to five?
Yes? No? May- Huhh NO
No
Nope- No
One
Ehh
One!
ONE!
You alright two?
You good? Two's good
Okay, Two's good
Okay- Uh WHYY SEVEN AND EIGHT
Why the farthest ones?
You sack's of shit
Okay I'm gonna go to seven first, just because I can
Cause I thought it was go- I think that one went down first
Eight x10 gimmeee
Something else went down
Something else broke
Of course! It broke
oohh
No- NOO  I'm fine
Uh let me get this one first- NEVERMIND no I won't
Let me try to go for this one first
*mumbles*
oooh
Less than a minute- Ten percent power
OH I'm fucked
I am fucked
I am exceptionally fucked
I am unbelievably fucked
I am ludicrously fucked
OHH Fuck!
Ohh f- OH
F- FUCK
Got close- NO
No- Hey!
Woah!- Wait!
Woah
*Miss Eyesore noise*
HEY!- Oh fuck
*exhale*
Thats hard!
But good! I like that
The mechanic is tight- The mechanic is really good
The mechanic is- The mechanic's okay
Let's try that again
I think we can do that
Now that I- Now that I know what I'm doing
Now that I really know
I just need to be more efficient about the directions that I go to get what I need to get
And know I know to run- Like the whole time
Maybe it might be- It might behoove me to wait like for like a few-
If I know I'm gonna be running of into a distance like-
Just to see
Yeah but I'm not gonna do that
I'm just gonna try to gun it
Nine of nine
Eight of nine- So one just went down
I've got to pay attention to that too
Eight of nine, so one is down
If another goes down then I got to like inspect
Where did it break? x6
We've got two down- Oh shit
Well this is one where Ive got to make a choice right?
Aw fuck me
Aw fuck me it's already falling apart
Yeah it's like as soon as you get one thats like away from another it falls apart
And then everything goes to shit and--
Oh Goddamn it oh- Oh fuck me
Thats got to- AHH I SAW THAT!
I saw you Miss Eyesore!
I saw you Miss Eyesoreee
Uh shit- Well lost one already
I'm gonna lose another one if I'm not careful
Which I'm not
If I lose this one, I lose two of them
Please- Yes
Okay
Another one went down
Oh fuck me- Oh GO
GO THROUGH THE FUCKING THING YOU FUCKING ASSHOLE
Okay two minutes left- We've got plenty of power for two minutes left
Thats pretty good
Seven and nine- Thats pretty good!
I think one's down? Yeah- Oh two's down
Okay I'm gonna go to eight first I think
Or nine first
I think the other one went down juust before that
So thats fine
This one- Oh another one went down
So this is where things are gonna go bad because
Things are just going to start "domino-ing" down and I won't be able to control it
Shit!
No- Oh it was fine!
Oh Goddamn it ok well... gonna have to live with that one now
Ohh shit-fuck
Okay, alright
It wasn't broken when I walked by it before, so why would it be broken now?
*grunt*
This game is stressful
*mumbles* too stressed
Too stressed
Oh well thats gonna be- Oh thats gonna bite me in the ass
Oh- don't break x6
Ohh its gonna bite me
My ass! My ass!
My ass is about to be bitten
Oh fuck me- One minute left
One minute- OH shit both of those just went down
Oh fuck, Oh fuck, Oh thats down
Wait, no did I-
*says shit repeatedly*
EAYY! SHIT
FUCK ME FUCK
I'm gonna run out of power FUCK
I'm so close No, Noo, Not like this
Not like this x6
OHH never mind
Not like this!
NOT LIKE THIS
NOTT LIKEE THISS! NOO
Shit! Ah Titty sprinkles
AHHH FUCKK MEEE!
AHHH
Thats hardd
Ughh Oh well
I'm gonna call it. Im gonna call that one
That was it for now
We played a great game , and some pretty alright games...
And then some bottom of the barrel games
So thank you everybody so much for watching!
And as always...
I'll see you, in the next video...
BUH BYEEE!!!
*lit outro music*